transparence totale le cnes le centre
national d'études spatiales met en ligne
ses archives sur les ovnis et son site
internet a été presque aussitôt saturé
par les requêtes d'internautes férus ou
pas de phénomènes inexpliqués c'est le
dossier de ce 19,4 et qu'espèrent ils
gardent une lumière bizarre dans ciel
nocturne
cela ressemble souvent à cela ne veut ni
parfois c'est une mystérieuse soucoupe
volante
ici il s'agit en fait d'un lampadaire de
jardin mais les plaisanteries de ce
genre restera le centre spatial de
toulouse conserve les archives de 6000
témoignages concernant 1650 cas
d'observation placé sous la
responsabilité de l'ingénieur jacques
pas tenaient des cartes des objets des
procès verbaux 1971 un pilote de mirage
poursuivi par un ovni janvier 80 une
soucoupe métallique se pose dans un
jardin à trans-en-provence laissant des
traces au sol janvier 94
l'airbus d'air france croise un
gigantesque disque jusqu'ici seuls
quelques privilégiés avaient accès à ces
procès verbaux de gendarmerie et à ces
documents confidentiels du cnes
désormais d'un seul clic de souris
chacun pourra se faire sa propre idée
sur les ovni en visitant le site
internet du centre national d'études
spatiales
cette mise en ligne est destinée à
mettre fin au mythe du complot
une nécessité suite aux nombreuses
critiques essuyées par le cnes plusieurs
fois le service chargé d'étudier ces
phénomènes avait été réorganisées mais
la consigne de silence était resté
aujourd'hui le tiers des cas restent
inexpliquées
comme cette histoire survenue à sierre
ce en haute garonne durant une série de
phénomènes en 54
un homme circulait avec sa charrette à
cheval son meilleur ami raconte ici
surgi d'un buisson un objet qu'ils
assimilent immédiatement une lessiveuse
qui s'élève du buisson qui se plombe la
cayolle qu'à ce moment là qui attire qui
inspire le la jument puis qui sait
qu'ils s'évadent qui disparaît dans le
siècle et des gui gui à ce moment là est
sidéré il est paralysé le peur
l'observation et le témoignage de sierre
s'insère parfaitement dans cette notion
de vagues et en particulier en 1954 où
durant un mois un mois et demi la france
a été l'objet d'observations de nature
tout à fait insolite d'objets rapproché
avec lesquels parfois déjà envoyé des
personnages ingénieur aérospatial
jean-jacques velasco a été responsable
du service du cnes durant trente ans il
a pu consulter
trente mille documents américains
déclassifiés comme cette affaire
concernant un site atomique survolé par
un engin le radar d'un b 52 avait pu
enregistrer sa trace la conclusion les
performances aéronautique détecter
notamment par les radars en terme de
vitesse d'accélération de trajectoire
semble incompatible avec les aéronefs
les objets que nous serions capables de
concevoir et fabriquer ce qui veut dire
que si nous ne sommes pas capables
aujourd'hui de réaliser de tels objets
c'est qu'ils sont fabriqués par
quelqu'un d'autre qui viennent
d'ailleurs
d'où le fait que l'hypothèse
extraterrestre semble la plus plausible
claude poher le premier directeur du
service en 1977 avait dû démissionner
lui aussi est convaincu que le phénomène
est d'ampleur considérable le comprendre
nécessitera selon lui d' inventer une
science physique entièrement nouvelle